somebody who knows dan's show and our
show very well um
who i think deep down feels like he's
cheating on dan every single time he
appears on the rich eyes and show but
that might just be a me thing that's um
oh it's that's a that's a that's a yp
right it's a your problem not an mp
what's up chris mannix from the bubble
in orlando uh joining us here
on the rich eisen show from sports
illustrator how are you christopher
i do rich feel like i'm doing something
unsavory
every time i appear on the show
it does feel like infidelity in a way
you know what though chris i feel like
you and i have our own chemistry
or chemistry as dan might might point
out and um you know and i think
i think it's fine i think there's
there's enough manics to go around
it really is chris i really believe that
i think so uh we do have to find our
our true basketball connection though
like in the bubble the last couple of
weeks
yes uh every time ricky rubio made a
shot i would take a picture of him
and send it to dan and just alert him
that ricky rubio is
the greatest point guard in the history
of international basketball yeah he'd
flood his
his text messages with i understand that
you've been you've been uh dying on that
rubio hill for quite some time
uh chris oh so long so so long
so long that i i don't even remember
when it began in fact
so um let me let's start with life in
the bubble are you there for the
duration
chris are you locked in there for the
direction
i've been here since july 12th
i'm planning on tapping out in early
september
um we have another writer from si mike
rosenberg is going to come in and
finish my i mean i really wanted to be
here
for when i'm here like the beginning
stages when all 22 teams were here
uh and some of the stories you can write
off of that um
i'll still cover it but it's uh you know
it's less to me it's less valuable
as a reporter you know as the the teams
get whittled down to eight
at four right so um what has life been
like
weird um how would you describe
the bubble experience for everybody
because part of the conversation we're
already hearing now that the rubber is
meeting the road
elimination rounds have
have arrived the conversation about
teams that are
comfortable uh in the bubble as opposed
to teams that are not potentially the
lakers being one of those
yeah i mean i i've found that
players are starting to get into
something of
a bubble rhythm for lack of a better
phrase
um they don't i mean they experimented
with social activities early
whether it was fishing or golf and golf
is still played by
a lot of guys out there every single day
but i think players have found
some some sense of of rhythm
with you know hanging by the pool and
hanging out with teammates and
you've seen stuff you know on social
media with you know
uh madden tournaments that the lakers
are playing and some other teams are
doing similar things
as well i think the biggest you know the
biggest thing we're seeing this in the
first round already
is that teams that like philadelphia
that go down 0-2
you know ordinarily you know the sixers
would have you know the benefit of a
home crowd
you know in a building they went 31 31-4
in in the regular season try to get that
momentum back
they don't have that and so these teams
that go down early
um you know they find themselves without
the
the boost that comes with playing in
front of their home crowd so
the adjustment right now is more about
what you're getting and really what
you're not getting from
from these arenas on the floor i mean
there's just you're going to see
some of these teams really react
differently as the series progress
well let's uh start uh let's start
unpacking that a little bit um the
sixers
uh we were having a little bit of fun uh
but usually there's a germ of truth in
every single
uh joke i'm not saying they are a joke
but we were just joshing around
that this is the end of the process the
process is officially needing to be
2.0 3.0 or just blown up with what's
going on with the sixers what do you say
yeah i mean look the the everything
every conversation about philadelphia
has to be taken with the caveat that ben
simmons isn't playing
and simmons is one of the best point
guards in the league and all star
you know an elite defensive player so
when you lose a player of that caliber
you lose a lot and you know they're
replacing him in the lineup with
with uh matisse tybalt who's a rookie
you know fake milton
was in the g league last year he's their
starting point guard uh
so i mean there's a roster element to
all this that
has to be taken into account but what is
inexplainable
and i was at the game against boston
last night the effort that was displayed
was just inexcusable
i mean they got up early but when joel
when embiid went out
and boston picked up the tempo they just
folded i mean they just showed no energy
in the second half of that game no
effort in the second half of that game
it's easy to beat up on brett brown and
ultimately if they wanted getting swept
or beaten five games he's probably going
to pay the price
but if you're a professional player
you've got to play with more energy than
that
like that that was just the effort was
just non-existent for philadelphia
in that game so i'm not a believer that
you have to break up the simmons mb core
these are great players
that are still very much in their early
to mid 20s uh
i think you just need to find the right
chemistry around them i mean they
started this year rich
without shooting they let jj reddick
walk jimmy butler left
and they didn't replace them with any
capable shooters like if you have two
players like
embiid and simmons the other 10 guys
that are in your
on your active roster need to be
shooters all of them
and if they're not you're not doing
those players any favors out there on
the floor so to me this starts with
elton brand in the front office
you know being better at uh putting the
right talent around those two players
that said chris i mean wasn't the
conversation about the sixers
pre-covered
during the 70-game regular season that
we saw
prior to the stoppage all about that
simmons and embiid
were were not mixing well on the floor
at all
and might not actually be the
you know obviously when you've got two
superstar players that's what you need
in the nba and you can add a third
that's what puts you definitely over the
top potentially
but if the two superstars don't
complement each other or they can't
figure it out or it can't be figured out
that's a problem wasn't that the
conversation about the sixers
it's it was a conversation but i do
think you have to
zoom out if you will and look at it in
the bigger picture that
the team they had last year was not
brought back
and what happens rich if that kawhi
leonard baseline jumper
takes one extra bounce and falls out and
the sixers go on to win that game
are we having an entirely different
conversation does philadelphia win the
championship maybe i mean toronto went
on
to win the whole thing with philadelphia
i mean is it really as simple as
one bouncing ball changing the
perception
of this team i think where philadelphia
made a huge mistake
was not paying jimmy butler like it
would have been an expensive team that's
for sure
but jimmy butler has been brilliant for
miami this year
and the sixers didn't believe that in a
five-year contract
jimmy butler would be able to stay
healthy enough and produce enough
to live up to that money that was a
mistake butler on that team
would have given them the shooting the
extra playmaking and the gravitas they
need to win
you know a series like like they're in
with boston that you know
i don't i think this is less about
simmons and embiid and far
more about the kind of players that are
being put around them chris mannix of
s.i
senior writer here on the rich eisen
show we had your colleague from the la
times tanya ganguly on the show
yesterday she's been covering the lakers
as we all know
uh there in the bubble um mentioning
that you know the lakers shooting woes
in the bubble
are are just a it's just a matter of
time till they fall at least that's the
way that
frank vogel and the staff are taking a
look at it uh they're one game down now
we all know
charles on tnt is saying the sweep is
coming um
are are you concerned or do you have the
mindset of
okay it's it's all set up that just the
shots just have to start falling
i mean you have to be concerned if for
no other reason
then they're up against what is arguably
the greatest eighth seed in nba history
i mean the blazers are not an ac they're
a conference finalist
masquerading as an eight seed because of
everything that happened pre-pandemic
with the health of their roster so
you're not going up against you know a
group of stumble bums that are
not going to be able to produce like
they did in game one
all that being said you know danny green
is a proven playoff shooter kyle kuzma
shot 44 from three during the restart
the looks the lakers got in game one
were great ones and every time i talked
to
a coach or an executive in the hallways
of these hotels out here i asked them
the question like are you worried about
the lakers
uh you know the lakers struggles are
they are concerned to you and
more often than not i'd say 90 percent
of the time the answer has been no
because
as these coaches point out it's similar
to what you just said all it takes is
one practice
or one meeting or one quarter even for
them to get it right
for that for these shots to start to
fall and look they were in this game
against portland
to the bitter end shooting 15
from three like that is an abomination
of a number
and they were still in this game at the
end if they make you know five percent
more of those shots
they probably win the game against
portland i just look at the lakers
and i think they'll make more threes in
this next game
and if they do they'll win the game and
they'll win the series
i don't think portland had a great
defensive game i think the lakers just
missed all their shots i mean you're
mentioning that the blazers are
an uh a conference finalist masquerading
as an eight seed
uh you know you got the mavericks as a
seven seed right you've got uh
uh i mean the rockets right there in the
middle of the pack
you see what the jazz and the nuggets
are doing to each other
we all know the clippers have george and
obviously kawhi and others but
this is anybody's tournament right in
the west wouldn't you say like
any of the teams i just mentioned could
do it all of them
right in in the west in the east too i
mean i wrote the start of all this
uh on monday that it was the most wide
open
field there's ever been there is no
favorite in all this it's just
because of everything that's happened
it's impossible to
you know put any kind have any kind of
confidence in predicting even
a finalist from from either conference
the west though
you know could get especially wild i
mean if you're the clippers
you know you're at practice today you're
saying to yourself we are
you know one stupid chris porzingis
technical foul
away from being down o2 i mean they're
up five in that game one the mavericks
were
before porzingis went out and you know
luca just got gas
down the stretch and couldn't hold on
but mavericks are right there i mean
they could have been up two nothing in
the series
and for a young team you're giving them
a lot of confidence going into
into this game three so you've got to be
really anxious
if you're the la clippers and you've got
to start making some some adjustments
out there and you've got to hope
that montrez harrell uh gets his uh you
know his win back as
we get into more of these games you got
to cross your fingers hope patrick
beverly can come back at some point
because defensively
he is really key to what they do
especially against a guy like luca
doncic but
you've got to be really anxious if
you're the clippers given how those
first two games have gone
what about westbrook is he are we gonna
see him soon or or not at all i mean
what's the scoop on him
not soon from the people i talked to you
know within houston
the concern in houston is not the state
of his injury right now
but the likelihood that if he comes back
too soon
you get a more significant version of it
now that's that's been kind of the
the message coming out of the rockets
and look they gave themselves a little
bit of a cushion
winning that game one it gave mike
d'antoni and that team
uh more reason to to let them you know
sit westbrook on the sideline so
he's going to miss game two and you know
if they win game two it wouldn't
surprise to see them try to stretch this
out
and just make sure that he's fully
healthy when he comes back i mean the
thunder have been a great story all
season long but as you saw in that game
one they
they just don't really have the
firepower to match up with uh with
houston in a series like this few more
minutes left with chris maddox at sports
illustrated senior rider calling in from
the orlando bubble
uh is the draft lottery happening in the
bubble tonight walk me through this
what's going on with the draft lottery
this evening sir yeah the lottery
is is happening it's kind of you know
unique circumstances obviously because
it's all being done
virtually and you know for the most part
i mean over the last five or six years
i've been in that draft lottery room
kind of disturbing because it's kind of
cool to see how
the whole thing plays out um it'll be
entirely different this time around but
man
there are some high stakes in this in
this draft lottery i can tell you a lot
of top
executives out here are you know kind of
nervously watching wondering if the
warriors wind up with that number one
hit
the warriors will have yeah as much a
chance as anyone i mean look
if you're golden state and look it's to
be clear it's not a great draft i mean i
don't know who's number one whether it's
anthony edwards
james wiseman lamellar ball is in that
mix but if you have the number one pick
and a big contract you can move in an
andrew wiggins which the warriors have
you might be able to get somebody big i
don't know who's available right now but
uh you know somebody always comes on the
market you know whether it's
circumstances for a team or something
else
and if you're armed with a top pick and
a big contract you can get something
that fits into they get a player that
fits into the timetable
that steph curry clay thompson and
draymond green are on so
the warriors are kind of sitting back
right now being goofy on social media
but
you know they're the the elephant that's
not in the room so to speak i mean
they're
you know everybody's gonna be watching
that draft lottery night i guarantee you
just cringing
if the warriors wind up with number one
well let's stir it up give me some names
that you think the warriors could uh
could add
with a a wiggins dangle as you say
uh because they've got the number one
overall pick in their back pocket
give me you know it's just hard to it's
hard to say right now
right because you know the teams i've
talked to like a lot of teams
are going into next season believing
they're contenders at least for a
playoff spot i mean look at the western
conference rich
who's the worst team in the western
conference next year i mean
probably minnesota you'd say off the bat
but the timberwolves will have
you know two all-stars in towns and
russell and a young group that gets
better look up and down those standings
you know it's a fight one through 15. so
i don't see a team outside of maybe san
antonio
that could be looking to move off uh you
know a player and you don't
you don't trade the top pick for
lamarcus aldridge so it's hard to
to sort of see the landscape right now
but it as it always happens
you know a team changes direction in the
off season maybe makes a coaching change
or
you know a new tm decides that a player
is not as valuable as the other
previous regime thinks he was so
somebody's gonna be out there and the
warrior is gonna be more armed than
anybody else
to go and get that player okay so um
so is this how's it gonna look tonight
like uh the uh
deputy commissioner mark tatum in his in
his basement
on one zoom and then the ping-pong balls
on another zoom
and then um nervous executives on their
own
zoom boxes the knicks will try to choose
somebody from their past
that actually can stand being in the
same room as james dolan to stand there
and try and be lucky for them and
won't be lucky because dolan's karma
sucks um i've set this all up for you
uh chris what is that what it's gonna
look like tonight essentially did i lay
it out
basic basically i mean basically it's
it's everybody
uh beaming in virtually each team will
have their usual
you know kind of goofy representative
you know from that group
uh and it'll it'll play out like that
but
it's it's just gonna be fascinating to
see who winds up with
i mean the knicks i think they've got
the ryan lamello ball and gosh
i mean if lamelo and levar wind up in
new york i mean i don't know
oh please let that happen oh my gosh
oh my god levar from los angeles you're
on the fan is that what you're saying
like that's the way it's going i mean
well i mean play this play it out a
little bit further rich i mean you put
lamella in new york you've got tom
thibodeau there as well
you know the idea of lavar ball lobbing
grenades and tibs from
you know section 115 of the garden you
know once they get back in there
that's got to make some i know what
makes them nick and jackie is extremely
nervous so it's uh
that's a scenario that could be some
interesting copy for the tabloids in new
york i should say so
chris stay safe in the in the bubble
we'll chat again soon i always
appreciate our conversations thanks
brother
anytime richard you guys chris mannix
you can follow him at si chrismanics on
twitter
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here